[Music]
so I'm Francesca and today we try to
give some insights into our super
solution project that we've been doing
for the past few months a key diallo
which is a price conversion company
which is kind of irrelevant for the
moment so i will show you why we did if
any diallo why we started with this
project at first and then i'm gonna just
show you what image resolution is single
image resolution is in the context of
deep learning so i'm gonna go through a
little bit of the literature to give you
an overview what kind of came from and
where it's now as well as showing you
some networks actually one network and
the egos of it then I would then I will
proceed to show you the standard
approach for it what the problems with
this approach are and some of the
results and then we're gonna try to fit
this algorithm this technique to our
needs so we're gonna try to have some
perceptual improvements including
denoising we're gonna use some features
coming from other networks and of course
at the end we introduce an adversarial
loss because that's that's that's good
with images and at the end if there is
time we're gonna have a look at model
averaging which is convenient in this
context and latency issue if time allows
so business motivation this is this is
literally the second page ever visited
on ideale web page it's one of the
products on the product catalog it's a
coffee grinder like coffee I wanted to
buy my own and I found this page and if
you click on the image there and kind of
could see the details and everything you
could see if this is actually what you
need and this is what you would expect
like a picture because a fills up but
this is what you get kind of lonely
picture in the middle of white and well
that's not really desirable
it's the looks of it so this is like why
we could do this but the real thing is
that it's an interesting project so
that's why we want to do it and this is
what it's what it looks like to do super
resolution with neural nets
on the left side on the left-hand side
you have low resolution input so small
image which you feed through a
convolutional neural network wait a doc
this spits out a super salt output so a
larger image yeah
and you compare it with the original
that you have in your data side you
compute some loss you back propagate
update the weights repeat until you're
happy so this is what it looks like for
the very basic part of it so on top here
we still have the original we compare it
with a here mean squared arrow you can
use mean average error actually that
converges better but there is more
things to it you could do you may have a
better loss and now I'm just gonna give
you an overview what it looks like but
then I'm gonna go through details a
little more
so if good for example add to your to
your loss a feature X structure so
basically a for example here a
complication at the vgg network you feed
to the network both of your images and
compare them at some features that this
network extracts and yeah add it to your
loss and you could also add as I said
the adversarial network so this is the
big picture let's have a look so this is
again the literature at 13 2015 with
long ago where they basically approach
it as a image reconstruction problem
they would upscale it with some baseline
technique and then make it look better
then from 2016 they went from a more
antwine approach which is more common
and the last three papers are the ones
that I'm gonna take elements from to
construct our final sort of say model
specifically I'm gonna choose the
residual dance Network for image super
resolution which was publishing 2018 and
I'm gonna show just after this slide I
think why we chose this but basically
sorry to ensure the network but the
reason why we chose is is that it
basically had lightest architecture
thanks to some clever tricks they used
such as residual connections
and was the best at the time on the
common evaluation metric which is
basically what people compare the
various approaches with which is going
to turn out to not not to be the best
thing to use for evaluating your model
but you can see that later thanks to
being lighters is less later hungry and
all the other components that we're
featuring other papers can be added that
at the end such a multi scaling or all
the rest so as a core solution that was
that was good
and this is what it looks like it's
actually a fairly common structure sorry
four four four is our networks you have
again on the left-hand side low
resolution input one convolutional layer
one or multiple and then you have this
kind of block like structure these
blocks have their own shaping form but
you stuck very many of them and after a
while you connect all of them together
and process your output there's very
often a residual connection between the
very early layers and all the layers and
he'll and the output of the last layer
before the upscaling layer and after
this original connection which helps
with learning with vanishing gradients
and all these kind of things there is an
upscaling layer which is typically
especially recently implemented with a
pixel shuffle operation which rearranges
your your future maps into whatever you
want to look like with in this case it's
a double sized input/output then you you
reconstruct the image without have a
completion layer and there you have your
your high resolution output and this is
one this is the structure of the block
of the red parts up there as you can see
it's called residual dance block
residual because you connect the input
of the of the block to the output with a
addition operation a residual connection
and if called dance because every output
and every input is passed to all the
subsequent layers so the input of the
block is passed to the first to the
second to the chief
convolutional layer and for each output
of each college Commission leader you
the same so it becomes densely connected
between layers at the end again you do a
concatenation operation one by one
convolution and pass to the next block
there are a few things you need to
remember from this slide actually three
things and it's the letter C D ng g you
can see here but D is the number of
blocks we have in the network this is
gonna be useful later when we examine
like the time consumption basically so
you have D blocks and instead of the
inside of each block you have C
convolutional layers so if you have D
equals to 10 of 10 blocks C and 3 for
example commercial layers inside you
have 30 in total we actually gonna train
a network that has around 120 layers and
mind that all these operations that you
see all these densely connected arrows
they represent concatenation operation
so you basically concatenate all the
outputs ng write G is how wide this
convolutions are so how many feature
maps the output so for example is G is
64 you input to the first convolution
layer 64 feature maps to the second
you're gonna have a hun 2876 and so on
so it becomes very very wide very
quickly and this is the evaluation
metric so that peak to peak
signal-to-noise ratio psnr which is a
fancy name for a logarithmic scale mean
squared error negative so they higher
the better
we don't really need to focus too much
on this just remind remember that it's
pixel wise so we compare pixel by pixel
okay and this is the set up for the
first iteration the first training
session you had basically we use the
pixel wise mean square error as a loss
function and this is probably the thing
we're gonna change the most then we use
scarce because it's simple
which tends to flow back end and we
train on the diverse 2k open it asset
which is you can find online it was used
for a competition in 2016-17 it has 800
training images and I used 5 validation
images and there's actually this number
5 was to kind of stick with what the
papers we're doing I'm gonna change it
later because it yeah I don't think is
the best choice it's not enough and we
were feeling batches of 16 image patches
we've been training for one day on a p2
x-large
instance that was actually around 86
epochs of training and we monitor
everything with tensor board so if
you're somehow familiar with deep
learning you might ask yourself wait
wait a second why 800 images that
doesn't sound as a doesn't sound right
you billions right but the thing is that
each image so we don't we don't we're
not doing classification so we don't
need the entire picture we don't need to
find what elements are in the picture we
don't need to find the logical
combination between those elements so we
can just chop it up take patches small
ones and fit those to the network so if
you randomly extract patches from one
image and argument them you basically
have a letter that there's as large as
you need it to be of course if you have
more it is better but it's not crucial
so you can actually train on on such a
small data set and the reason why the
deceptively small is because data
quality is very crucial so yeah we
extract patches and we flee to the
network as a batch this is just what
training looks like so it's simple the
training loss and a vision loss they go
down no no doubt about that the training
Pearson R goes up so it works and this
is this is how you see it it just it's
fine and there's a sample image now this
highly relies on the resolution of the
screen so I don't know if you can see
the difference but basically on the on
the left hand side you have the original
image so patch is extracted from the
Rindell original image in the middle you
have a
patches that are taken from the bicubic
scaled image which we use as a baseline
which basically
normally when a new simple upscaling
with game for example and on the right
hand side we have the super resolved
output so I don't know if you can tell
but the details are crisper in the super
result image it's quite a bit better
than my cubic baseline basically the
main difference is that that's a little
more washed out whereas here it's able
to be kind of yeah sharpen everything
one thing you might notice is the psnr
values for the bicubic scaling baseline
the Pearson R values are around 30 for
0.5 and this is like basically 1.5 more
so it's not much but the perception
quality is there so the collective
difference is there so my merits that
they got between scale so it kind of
plateaus and small variations in psnr
might mean significant differences in
quality so to proceed that's all good
and fine but where does the model like
what are the problems of the model where
does it how does it work you know we're
going to have a look into this so i fat
that i upscale the entire validation
side and from each image i've chopped it
up and extract the patches with the
minimum and maximum psnr values to see
where it does well where it doesn't and
as you can see on the left side you have
the patches that have minimum guessing
our values and they are very rich in
detail
they are kind of there's many things
going on whereas on the right hand side
it's flat it's just basically colors if
I actually had to take larger images
larger patches because otherwise it
would just be really only colored
squares which wouldn't tell much but yet
this is one of the lower psnr attachés I
mean this is unsurprising right if it's
more detailed is probably more complex
to to upscale and this is one of the
lower psnr patches so still even though
it doesn't quite fit with the original
image you can see how it got sharpened
and liked it
the lines are kind of more we can kind
of make more sense and this is that to
give you
overview of what it what this values are
so light means good dark means bad lower
case in our values and you can see how
the the parts reaching detail or are the
ones that have a little work lower
values so so what's that that we want to
apply this to et al s product catalog
right we tried it and this is what we
got this is like a little sample in the
red boxes you have to buy cubic scaling
baseline and in the green boxes the
Super's old counterpart you can see that
again
details are more sharp but the issue
here is that those images are not great
and they have some JPEG artifacts and
also these artifacts get sharpen up and
that's not desirable
you might just kind of lose lose quality
so although it works well when you use
good images it doesn't do great when you
do this I mean it does well but it
doesn't know what to do yet so what are
the issues and the direction you should
take from here first the noise is
aggravated so we need to learn the
noising and to do this we said maybe we
can train on our own data we have the
same distribution maybe things were
better that idea our own data as we just
saw it has the JPEG artifacts and we
need really high quality data so the
difficulty that said for example is a
very highly curated data set check it
out it's good
another thing we could do is try
perceptual loss so those combination of
things that are surely before to kind of
ignore it and Draper artifacts which are
for example you relevant for
classification and try to have a lot try
to have the last function focus on on
what what really we wanted to focus on
which is the details and yeah biblical
prediction times it takes a very long
time
they with the network words I didn't
mention is I should have in those blocks
that you've seen basically it builds
different representation of the input
image very many of them and then it
combines them nonlinearly right but
those blocks tend to become very large
and the number of operation that you
have to
form is very high so it takes a long
time and so we're gonna have a look at
how the various parameters of Network
influence training time and sorry
prediction time and we're gonna have a
look how to train ladder model that kind
of balances speed and quality or we
could come up with a lyric texture which
luckily what I'm working on right now
but this is yeah in progress so maybe
not gonna say much about it so
compression artifacts okay we wanted our
denoising a reasonable thing to do would
it seems to be you take the input images
add some JPEG artifact to them and try
to ask the network to upscale it such
that it looks like the original one
without artifacts this sounds reasonable
I try to do it I try to control this so
I pre-process the data set with fixed
percentage of compression rate so for
example how 50 70 percent 80 percent and
when you look at the graphs
it's very more bumpy but it does go up
and it doesn't reach the levels that
with a similar number of epochs actually
here we retrain on top of the model we
had so it's sort of transfer learning
but not really exactly the same all of
it that we keep training on a different
data set and appears in our values they
don't reached as as high values anymore
but it is a harder problem so that was
to be expected the real issue here is
that it doesn't work great I mean it
does what you ask it to do on the left
side we have the original model and
these are two sample pictures again the
teddy bears I think they're good to show
this off and you can see that the more
you add compression rate to your
compression to your to your input images
the more it learns to remove them if you
look here on the right hand side there
is there isn't really money in
compression artifacts anymore they're
smooth but they're way too smooth like
all the details are gone and you might
have just used probably some some normal
denoiser for this
so it goes in sort of the right
direction but it does in the wrong way
so how can we how can we make it work
better okay as I mentioned before using
using features coming from a
classification network might help the
last function to focus on what is
relevant for classification which
happened to be correlated with what
people think
with perceptual quality feeling of
people so so basically what is relevant
for a human and for a network to
recognize an image are kind of the same
thing and deserve happen to be important
also for visual quality so the idea here
is okay we once we have the super
solution the super result image we give
it to the network to the vgg network
extract some intermediate layers and
compare those outputs point wise with a
mean squared error for example and
minimize this so if you do this again
you are minimizing in what matters for
classification lady here is is just like
from doctor button some deeper and
deeper layers of the BG network as you
can see it at the top the cat looks like
a cat and the more you go down the
lassie looks like a cat it's more
obstructed for example in the bottom
left second image those white and those
yellow dots could be the eyes for
example could somehow represent those so
we want to focus on these parts that are
they should care less about noise and
more about the relevant parts again good
we just we do it given our values are
even lower as you can see here they
reach around 26 which is the worst you
can get even if you use a normal
baseline get around 34 3 4 so so it
doesn't look great under psnr value and
on the left on the right you have the
loss evaluated on those features the
tray at the optimization landscape gets
little or a little more bumpy so you
need to be careful
had to find a learning DK schedule we
had to queue optimizes parameters
actually it's common that when you use
residual networks and very deep networks
you have to take care of you have to be
careful with the momentum part of your
of your optimizer and then again we're
retraining on the leaf to K with 50%
compression rate and this is what we got
so on the left hand side you have the
original model that was doing the
noising the naive way on the right hand
side you have the original model without
any denoising and in the middle you have
denoising using the using this lost
function using the GG features as lost
function and again the noise is kind of
gone and the Regals are more present we
use the same compression rate for both
trainings and so this is kind of going a
right direction I think this is right I
was already impressed on how well it
worked because what really like removing
part of the noise with no significant
drop in detail but here we can see the
rly there is some artifacts and it
doesn't look that great yet I think I
thought from here we could improve yeah
you can see specially here some square
light feel like artifacts are introduced
this is another example on a other part
of the image and again on the top you
have without these features and at the
bottom we add these features with
denoising and you can see for example
how the line of this cat on the Left I
assume is a cat or more marked so they
are focusing on lines which are helpful
for for recognizing the image and again
but there is some square like artifacts
I think this was I was already satisfied
with this result but I wanted to kind of
get rid of those artifacts so as a first
thing I tried to retrain on like taking
those features out to kind of remod the
image after it was focusing the right
things and it kind of works is something
between but you know this is just a fan
now let's let let's try to use Gans to
even go further from here so why we
wanted to do scans
except that everybody's doing it and
they're great well because they are
great they do they deliver excellent
results in terms of realism when you do
computer vision and basically they are
good at making sense of noise if you see
some examples like this website called
this person doesn't exist you have you
ever heard of this right No
so basically it's it's a website that if
you if you visit the page it's called
yeah this personality calm you go there
and they show you an image of a face a
face of someone then if you refresh you
this image changes and it's another face
and you can keep doing it forever
because those are not real faces those
are actually generated artificially with
cans
there's also Kitty website but those
kiddies are very creepy so just know
don't don't go I mean not go there it's
fun but they don't work always perfectly
so it's kind of and they have shown to
be working well in combination with
those the features that we've been using
so far so right let's use let's use this
oh yeah making sense of noise like the
way you generate those faces is just
feeding well then we generate some
realistic looking images is by fitting
random noise random vectors to it and
they kind of learn how to map those two
two things that that kind of makes sense
by learning from a data set so we could
use those to cancel the noise while
keeping the data level and by keeping of
course I mean making it up because it's
not there and then we just reproduce
what is what I've seen from other images
and and yeah this is what it looks like
the the vtg company is not there anymore
but it is still there and just for
showing you at the top we have the
training cycle of the the is our network
so the network does upscaling and in the
lower part we have the training for the
adversarial network this really
important here is to know that up here
we do not train the network the
adversarial network because what we're
trying to do there is fool it so we take
that low resolution input give it to the
is our network get the super-soul input
out and give
to the other serial counterpart mmm this
guy is gonna give us a output a tensor
which ideally we would like it to be
made up of once because that's that's
what we say it's a label for for a real
image of course the network is gonna
tell it probably this is not a real
image if it's not if it's not good then
we need to improve it but basically we
wanted to predict the wrong thing we do
cross-entropy
and update only the is our network and
here again we don't train it otherwise
it would learn to do the wrong thing in
the bottom we have the training cycle
for for the adversarial Network where we
just train it to predict the right thing
so high resolution image it should be
mapped to a valid or true enough label
and here again we don't use a number we
have a tensor of values between 0 and 1
just to give you a glance on what it
means to train these guys is so those
are the values on the left hand side you
have the psnr values of the generator
network so there is our network and on
the right hand side you have the loss of
the discriminator you can maybe notice
those are even validation validation
values so it's it's more stable than the
training the training is like ranging in
a huge span of psnr values but as you
can see they kind of oxalate they don't
really nicely converge to the top they
start at random points here actually the
various levels and the various colors or
because I was using different VG
features in it and different setups for
the discriminant network but the point
here is as you can see here on the right
hand side it never converges so it's
kind of in it's hard to tell when it's
done especially if your evaluation
metric is not the best and yeah I'm just
going to you later why and just have a
look to the results of this now so this
is the hue image that I show you before
and this is if we do upscaling
the basic way so so pixel wise error
without be noising now we introduce the
noising with a 50% compression rate of
the
data set and you can see that the yeah
the artifacts are gone but also detail
are are not that sharp anymore
this is what we got when we introduced
the VG features and again the little
definitely sharper but it looks squarish
so let's now try with guns and make it
look realistic
and there's some improvement from here
to here so the the artifacts are gone as
you can see here the kind of letter it's
clear the Vedas are marked you see the
lines there they're present the colors
shifted a little bit actually here I
made a mistake
I was yeah there was some mismatch
between input and output patches that
happens which are then fixed but this is
what you got if you so you can we can
really add some more realism touristic
touch to the images and this is again
trained to do compression to do
denoising if you didn't train for
luteinizing this would what you got and
here i corrected the color shift so it
looks a lot sharper there's like details
are elucidated but also the noise is
kind of elucidated as well so it's a
sharper but this is no ideal for every
case but they are nice and this is a
very common image in in the literature
this is a baboon picture on the top you
see top left you see the original and
here we do four times upscaling and
visit a bicubic baseline so if you with
any program and this is if you what you
get with the pixel by pixel driven
function loss and if you add guns things
become more interesting there is details
that we're not but I don't think it was
really possible to distinguish from here
but they basically have learned from a
later set and applied to this image so
you do you do reach a level of realism
which is beyond what you could normally
get by learning this dynamic loss
function yeah yeah
here I show you the effect so what you
had to do was choosing those VG feature
layers to fit it to train with and if
you choose different one you get
different results on the left of the
squirrels image you see the piece in our
training here everything looks pretty
decent anyways because it's it's from
far away and one thing that you probably
notice is if you use later layers so
deeper layers in the network such as
yeah the 20th 19th of the BG's 19 you do
get crispier details so everything looks
sharper but also you tend in result of
artifacts as opposed to the errors which
are which are less artifact prone but
but yeah less sharp so a good
combination is just use a wide range of
it so if you are to do this try to get
try to use many of those key features
layers it just works better so again a
little area or is it your control for
sticking with the original image so good
better colors no artifacts but they're
less detail as opposed to the later
layers which are harder to control they
tend to deviate from the original
original image but they do give you
short for details so yeah use a
combination of those model interpolation
so I'm gonna just quickly skip through
all of this basically to be noising is
something that is definitely depending
on what image you use as an input you
can might do more or less but basically
the way you achieve different levels of
the noising is by training on different
different ly compressed data sets and
that doesn't work for all images so you
don't want to have multiple models you
don't want to train a Aleph one model
just for having all the possibilities
and you don't want to do multiple
inferences for image because you could
have two models one that does a lot of
denoising and one that does nothing like
no denoising
and you could average the results but
again here there's low we don't want to
do move to Cali interesting so what
works here luckily is averaging the
weights of the of the network we trained
to or n models and take a weighted
average and by moving the parameter of
this average you do get consistent
results again here there is some color
shift
again because of the mistake I've made
but so this way you have all the range
without multiple inferences I'm with few
models which is good prediction times
yeah so just just to give you a inside
the C so the the the size of the blocks
influences quadratically on the
predictions times where as the number of
blocks influences linearly and the
effect is more and more evident the more
rigor the images are so to kind of
overcome this I have I used as
originally I used C equal to 6 and equal
to 20 so that's a hundred twenty layers
I hold both of those parameters and
feature maps to have a ten times speed
up and the perceptually the results are
kind of similar so the PSNI values vary
by a little bit but that doesn't matter
in applications I should get up to recap
doesn't matter and yeah if you want to
check it out we put everything I've done
all every code I've used every single
script in a nice package because you can
you can peep install I think it's good
because it's one major issue here was
tracking your experiments it was
actually my first deep learning project
so I didn't really know what the right
parameters at the beginning were to keep
track of it turns out everything is
important and if you think it's not it
is so I made up a I think a decent it is
an way of tracking your experiments to
customize everything and we give you
some free train rates which you can use
and in three lines of code for with the
import statement you can you can do
upscaling
so check it out it's on the yellow get
up page right thank you
[Applause]